il y avait foule au meeting duc tous et
au diamant l'ancien premier adjoint a su
rassembler les opposants de l'actuel
maire gilbert eustache
celui qui a claqué la porte de la mairie
en 2016 a composé une équipe de 29
colistiers et a proposé son programme
détaillé en trois axes de réflexion il
ne s'agit pas de créer un tourisme de
masse qui peut être dévastateur où notre
environnement mais un tourisme raisonné
accepté et partager avec la population
le premier axe concerne la population
parce que nous voulons
toutes les formes de solidarité dans la
commune à travers l'éducation le tissu
associatif les anciens
les seniors le deuxième axe repose
également sur les services à la
population donc nous voulons garantir un
service public de qualité à toute la
population
et enfin le troisième axe repose sur
tout ce qui est investissement projet à
savoir construire le diamant de demain
une tous et se présente pour la première
fois aux élections municipales et
communautaires avec le soutien du rdm en
2016 après de nombreux désaccords avec
le maire actuel
l'ancien premier adjoint avait
démissionné de son poste
ils dénonçaient la mauvaise gestion
financière de la commune après la
parution d'un rapport de la cour
régionale des comptes
aujourd'hui il propose plusieurs pistes
pour assainir les comptes du diamant si
nous nous retrouvons à cette position là
c'est parce que nous avons dénoncé un
certain nombre de manquements certain
nombre de dérives c'est tout l'enjeu il
faut faire mieux avec moins et donc
essayez de réduire la voilure mais aussi
c'est le terme qui me revient c'est la
mutualisation mutualisation des services
mutualisation avec météo communalité
gilbert eustache a annoncé qu'il ne se
représentera pas après deux mandats
il laisse donc un siège de maire va
qu'en ouvrant le champ des possibles au
diamant
[Applaudissements]